there's a lot of play in that there's a
lot of flexibility in that
and you know my theory chris we talked
about it not long ago
how do we explain the first round pick
last year and yesterday howie rosemont
was asked about
ignoring the board and didn't deny it
danced around it
right i think that howie roseman
is the in-house fall guy i don't have
anything to base this on other than
circumstantial evidence
common sense and an understanding of how
organizations
operate i think harry roseman is the
in-house fall guy to do the bidding of
jeffrey lurie
when he has a board different
from the board that the people he pays
to make the board
have come up with sure i i don't i don't
doubt that
i i don't i mean listen he's got to
listen to the owner that's for sure
jeffrey lurie seems like he's
you know definitely an owner that's
around a lot
and is trying and is learning football
and all the things that go into that and
wants to be involved somehow i
i got no issue with that either mike i'm
like you as long as you're
you know involved all the time not just
like coming in off your private plane
and being like
who we picking oh him no don't pick him
i was watching college football last
october
on a random saturday i want the other
guy that's the ones i have the problem
with
where it's like you you don't know
anything i don't know
you weren't here how do you know what
guy to pick that's that's the owners
that i have issues with
so yeah jeff i mean uh howie roseman
certainly got to be careful
of that you know are you trying to say
you think like lurie
drafted rieger last year and all that is
that what you're trying to
kind of say there i'm i'm trying to
explain and understand
deviations from the board yeah it's
either howie
going off the board on his own or it's
how he going off the board
because the guy who has kept howie in
place through multiple regimes and for
whatever reason there's this perception
that howie is untouchable
that howie is the guy that allows
jeffrey laurie to tinker with the draft
board
to get the guys he thinks are the best
fits for the team
without ever being publicly perceived
right as a meddler and and i can look at
this and i could say
you know what if you want to do that
just make yourself the general manager
like jerry jones did yeah but that isn't
gonna fly in philly
one of my favorite sayings the only
thing better than being rich and famous
is being rich
the more jeffrey lurie can stay away
from the fray
the less chance he he
assumes of becoming as reviled as the
individuals who make the bad decisions
what's my decision well
i'm not the gm yeah i hear you he's got
he's got he's got an ear
it gets back to this quite people think
that owners aren't involved
baloney they're they're involved
especially in the first round this is
their organization they're the ones
paying the money this is the guy that's
either going to lift
or kill the franchise over the next
several years of course the owners are
involved and if they're not they
should be but laurie may be more
involved
sounds like it listen look at it this
way if
if you're compil watching
all-star games and watching tape and
taking the time to gather the
information what are you going to do
with that information
you're going to do what anyone else does
that does all that what do you do
you make a list yeah of your players
right that you like at the various
positions so lurie's got his list
yeah and i i think lurie's got his
scouts have theirs sure and i think how
he's the one
i don't harmonizes it and his ongoing
employment
yeah may be best explained by the fact
that he's running interference
for jeffrey lurie's side gig
of being amateur mel keiper yeah right
also happens to own a football team
i don't doubt you there mike i don't i'm
sure howie's had to take a few you know
you know right hooks to the face at
jeffrey lurie's expense in the media and
things like that i i don't i don't
question that at all
i don't know if i'm going to buy it for
last year with jalen rieger because
we've just heard too much
around the nfl i know both of us have to
think like uh
it sounds like it's howie i think that's
one where
if it was the owner's pick it had kind
of gotten
out a little bit well well no not if hey
i know maybe not not if howie is fully
and completely
protecting jeffrey that's my point i get
you if you're
so committed to taking the bullet for
jeffrey laurie and your reward is you
don't get
fired when everything goes sideways that
may be the best way to explain why he
hasn't gotten fired it could be if lori
hires a new gm
he's got to start from scratch yeah with
that relationship where you have nuance
and subtlety
and maybe you've got a general manager
who
when you try to tell them what to do
tells you to go to hell
right i'm the general manager you hired
me look at my contract i've got final
say over the draft you got a problem
with that fire me
and and and buy out my contract but you
hired me to do this job mr lurie
i expect you to respect that you got to
start from scratch
with that relationship he's got a guy
if my theory is right and i kind of
think it is
he's got a guy who will do what he wants
him to do
sure any any and and it's it's
comfortable yeah
it's simple it works yeah well maybe it
doesn't work
they won a super bowl though they did
they want a super bowl so
maybe it does work no i know listen i
mean i don't look at the eagles as a
poorly run organization that's for sure
and like i said i got no problem with
jeffrey luery sitting there doing all
those type of things
you know and a lot of times with those
kind of scenarios if the guy is involved
a little bit in football and know that
like it's good to have another pair of
eyes and ears and those type of meetings
you know what one one thing that you
know can happen with
coaches and scouts they're in the weeds
of the game so much
and you know they overanalyze like we've
talked about and all that type of stuff
to where like i have i have friends in
the nfl right
i have like four or five guys that i
really talk ball with like really talk
ball
and sometimes they'll say thing we're
talking about two players
and they're telling me about two players
and they like this one guy
a little more than the other guy but the
guy they like less
they keep saying like all these good
things about and they compare
him to a better player and the guy they
like more you know yeah there's some
things they say good but you can also
see
hear a few things that you're like wait
he said a few concerning things there is
he listening to the words that are
coming out of his mouth here
and that's sometimes where that value
can be you know
good we go hey listen you know you did
you kind of just said this you know to
to me
are you sure about what you're saying
there it sounds like you you know you
like this guy more or you see something
in this guy more
and you're just being a hair nitpicky or
something like that so that's where it
can be helpful
but yeah eagles big draft really big
draft for them to kind of get back on
track here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports